(audience applauding)
- Well, I have to say this
because I think this is very beautiful
and poetic and magical.
I know that you and the late Paul Walker
y'all kind of have this thing
that's saying that y'all,
you wanted it to last 10,
you were like, "How many
can we get out of it,
do you think, with this franchise?"
(audience applauding)
And the goal, I heard the
goal was to get to 10.
Is that true?
- Paul and I started,
let me take you back.
We were in Mexico before the
first film had ever opened.
We were sitting at an airport.
Our duffle bags were at the side.
We were sitting on the floor.
We had just come from this place called
MTV Spring Break thing that they had.
- Haha, I've done that before.
- You know what I mean.
- That's crazy.
- It was crazy.
And he said to me,
"Vin, take all this in."
As people are walking over our feet
and not looking at us.
And he said,
"Take in the fact that we have anonymity
because once this movie comes out
we will no longer have anonymity."
(audience applauding)
- Aw, the pride in that. That's amazing.
He believed in it.
- He believed in it.
And he would always say,
whenever we would go to a
premiere around the world,
whenever I would exit the theater
it would only be him and I.
No other directors, writers, producers,
studio, cast, nobody.
It would just have to be him and I.
And he'd always whisper in my ear and say,
"Vin, the best one's still in the can."
And we were doing an interview in London
and they asked him,
we had just done six, and they said
"Is there gonna be another one?"
And he said, "Vin, is
there gonna be anymore?
Is there gonna be a seven
and eight and a nine?"
And I said, "The question
isn't, is it seven?"
I'm gonna confuse you.
"Seven, eight, nine.
It's, is it seven, eight, nine, ten?"
And when I said 10, he
looked at me and said
"If we ever got to 10
we would do something
no one's ever done in cinematic history."
And now ten has come out.
(audience applauding)
- So it's incredible that, like,
I know he was there in
spirit and at heart,
but he wasn't able to
be there for this 10.
But it's incredible to know that,
you know whatever you believe in,
he's looking down going,
"Damn, they did it. They made it to ten."
That's incredible.
It's an incredible franchise.
- Kelly, it's so crazy.
And I'm so grateful.
You know this is a franchise
that's never had an inherited fan,
meaning there's never been a comic book,
there's never been a TV show.
- [Kelly] Ground up.
- Ground up.
And it's just from you all
and the love that you all have
that has continued on this.
(audience applauding)
And who knew that in 2023
that we would need a saga like this
to remind us how important family is.
How important it is to
love each other, you know?
Yeah.